all right hot breath averse welcome back
this is the hot breath podcast the show
where you learn comedy from the pros
today we're doing our series comedians
on skype talking comedy where you get to
ask your favorite comedians your
favorite questions all of the questions
are being asked in our Facebook group so
if you'd like to join in the future if
you're listening on the podcast or
watching on YouTube go into the
description click join the Facebook
group and connect with hundreds of
comedians from around the world and get
access to some of the top minds in
comedy with no exception
to today's guest one of the most unique
voices in comedy prepare yourselves for
the one and only Jackie Kashian ladies
and gentlemen give it up for Jackie
everyone yeah let me uh there we go
let me make sure I'm uh that's what I'm
about to are you there
there it is yeah this is so okay cool
this is our first zoom and I think we
got it you think it worked it pushed and
it looks like it looks like we're
working that's such a relief so yeah so
I think this is very professional
everyone this is like comedians on zoom
figuring out technology so it looks like
I'm yeah I'm on there so we should yeah
I think we're good
let me just take down that so people in
the comments comment with your questions
and we are jumping off here and I'll
open up here just to ease into it
because we just watched you do an
hour-long zoom kind of practicing your
your next hour and right what's yeah and
I like you using the format in that way
and this is something you've been doing
every Thursday and a lot of times it's
been open mic setting I haven't really
seen a comedian use this time to
actually work towards like an in project
how long have you been doing this and
what are you working on here probably
since March
March I've just been doing at first it
started out because it's a it's a
different room right it's a different
venue but doing it online and if you end
up shouting into the internet there's no
back wall so we hard to know the timing
and all this stuff but the so I was just
I started out doing 20s and I was like
well I need because I'm so I'm supposed
to do an album I signed with 800-pound
gorilla to do a new album oh nice yeah
can you turn your volume up by any
chance yeah yeah I think they're saying
your how about that oh yeah a little a
little better yeah Michelle was saying
Yvonne's a little low so let's see a
little hot that sounds good right there
to me sounds real good yeah yeah so I
started doing twenties and then and then
I was like well 20s are great but
eventually there has to be an arc and it
has to so for the past three weeks I
think I've been just doing every
Thursday doing sixty minutes and it
turns out because what all my albums are
about 45 to 55 minutes
mm-hm and and this one I assumed was
going to be the same but because of
quarantine it's delayed it I've written
a lot of new material I pulled something
from the last album that I've decided to
put into this one that didn't make it on
to the last album and so I'm at 70
minutes right now that's a little long
for me anybody I mean I grant it I would
say live stand-up comedy no one should
and this is entirely my opinion I know
that I don't want to see the headliner
do more than our 15 mm and I as much as
mr. Chappelle is a genius I don't want
to see six hours of anything
nope yeah so what is that process if you
have like 70 minutes right now what is
it because I could were you actually
reading off the screen as well today
like were you know word for word
no no I was I was working off of my set
list
I was beneath you know okay the old this
is this is this week's notebook Carnegie
Hall has actually brought this oh no god
I know it it isn't right there's trouble
but there's trouble afoot I can do you
need a minute there I'll I'll fill it
buster I'll be your opener I'll do
something you can keep talking yes so
people yeah go ahead and comment with
your questions here thank you for
everyone that's tuning in and gave us
the heads up on the audio as well so
feel free to go ahead and comment with
your questions it's cool Justin Williams
is in here he was in the the live zoom
show he said hey killer shows so that's
great oh that's great hey this what is
was sitting on top of the only reason I
have to move it is that this is a short
box full of comic books we don't want
those to get trashed no we would rather
not know that everyone will be sad if
I've destroyed a month and a half of
x-men yeah I shouldn't have that I asked
about the writing and then III did that
and I apologize so yeah please go ahead
Oh Michelle said no no dab anymore thank
you Thank You Michelle I appreciate your
your support there so this is a first
this is good we've had guests bring
notebooks on here before but we've never
had them slam to him or drop them and
then accidentally spill coffee
everywhere so hopefully everything's
okay nothing is completely broken but uh
thank you to everyone that tuned in from
Jackie zoom call that's very cool this
is this your first time hearing about us
we're hot breath we started as a podcast
and now we're an online comedy
education platform and we do these QAS
every single week and we also have a
youtube channel with more interviews and
content as well as a weekly podcast so
if you love comedy and you love nerding
out about comedy this is your one-stop
shop for all of that
so I appreciate your support Michelle
and saying never dab again I guess you
and my wife have been talking because I
dabbed during my comedy special and she
still hasn't forgiven me
so Oh Danny says spilling coffee
everywhere is part of the process it's
part of the process I mean that's the
great thing about a live show you get to
see what's happening I know we got to
see like your Hot Wheels like the hot
wheel collection is is to speak of
ubiquitous yeah my husband is quite the
collector of many hot wheels that we
bought those rings so that I'd have
better lighting and then there's some
more hot wheels and then there's some
more hot wheels and that's his curio
shelves full of microdots
who doesn't love oh my god
what's a micro not it's a it's an action
figure
oh good I'm just gonna stack board games
that we have we haven't got to play
because there's just the two of us and
so that's a new one
we've played this one here's fickle I
don't know what it is I can't remember
but here's here's real nice it's gonna
stack it up high so you both you both
like you're both collectors no no he's a
collector oh he's just like oh I like
board games and video like literally
this is I will also show you that that's
the the filing system for the comic
books oh okay and I'm so there they're
being sorted that we have 10,000 comic
books in this house and it's 950 square
feet so it's it's pretty glamorous and
he likes stuff so mmm when we moved in
together
he was like you'll never
the bread has lifted up high enough that
we can slide the boxes under he doesn't
talk like that
and so yeah but it's been it's been a
jerk he's a game designer so he has an
art guy so he's got a lot of fun it's
got a lot of stuff that he needs to
collect I guess oh but that's that's
love and are you one of these comedians
I like myself that has like boxes of
notebooks as well I mean you've been
doing comedy since the 80s have you have
you kept kept up with all of your notes
and all that I have I have kept up and
it is it is obnoxious because I like
something I realized how silly it was to
keep those notebooks when Marc Maron
told me that he kept all of his
notebooks because he feels like when
after he's gone people go through him
and realize the genius that he was and
I'm like yeah nobody's nobody's gone
through a knock books man and and then I
realized how and I was telling Bamford
that and Bamford was like well you know
I I throw out my notebooks Maria Bamford
I was like you do what what and because
I mean it cuz here's the thing when I go
from one notebook to the next notebook
ideally what I do is I I take like this
the set list but I'm working on and I
transcribe it into the new notebook and
then I also go through the old notebook
and and and find all the bits that never
got fleshed out or anything and I will
copy that into the new notebook so the
first four pages of every notebook is
essentially you know the last notebook
summarized by hand yeah yeah cuz I mean
get back in the yeah it's just a
dinosaur there's a band writing going on
for sure I've heard and I don't have it
you know like dad fan and iliza
shlesinger on Last Comic Standing would
talk about their Excel spreadsheets and
how they've added and then did you see a
Joan Rivers documentary yes the card
catalog the card catalog whole area
you're like alright I'm nuts but I'm not
that not world thuds I mean why do I
have I would I watched Maria she was I
was like you throw them out and she goes
yeah want to see me do it right now but
but eBay she was like don't touch it and
it was and she only she uses CBS
notebooks she just likes a ring like a
school notebook I for a long time was
using those cardboard the the card the
ones that look like school primers oh
yeah like the composition books
yeah composition that's what I have
right back here yeah yeah and then I
have some friends who like to use a
yellow pad like a yellow pad this is
kind of my favorite it's kind of a
moleskin II kind of thing mm-hmm and and
it's nice that it has lines lines are
lines ooh nice
but it doesn't have to because I tend to
write I tend to I tend to write like
just all over anyway right oh yeah let's
see the budget yeah so are you
do you like do freehand journal and then
Whittle ideas together like do you have
like a almost like a checklist you can
put ideas through now no I tend to do
bullet points more than anything I just
use keywords the jokes on the set list
the joke might have five lines the first
month I do it and then by the end of it
it's just one line oh my god
same day you know I can then you know
it's like it's like a band setlist
where you're like oh I know what that
song is they don't write all the lyrics
down I mean until they're in their 90's
and they're still doing them but the
yeah so initially it's just it's many
different like that gender bit that I'm
closing on mm-hmm has about eight lines
to the setlist so make sure that I hit
all those beats mm-hmm and
eventually it'll just be called
something like the gender bit or
whatever but when you're exploring an
idea I mean I've heard you talk about
like you maria bamford will do you'll
play like joke machine yeah what it
would it what is that how you generate
ideas through that oh that that's great
matter of fact I was I was doing it
yesterday because I needed because I
it's very annoying to write new jokes
when you're trying to tighten up the
hour and hearing but this is a good joke
right and but the joke machine is
essentially you tell you hang out with
any comic and I do it with several
comics but you tell the comic that
you're hanging out with the joke or they
they tell you the joke and then you and
there's the only rule of joke machine is
you can't say why would you do a bit
about that anyway or you have to you
literally have to go well there's
something there you know and and the
feedback that can come from it if you
can think of it is sort of an anger
angle like like I have an old bit
Maria's classic on this one because
she'll be like she wants the specificity
she loves to know like I do this joke
about spooky reading girl and it's on
like two albums ago and it's about me
and junior high reading while I was
trying out for the basketball team in
ninth grade so I'm doing laps reading a
book and that's the funny image there's
a funny joke but Marie was like what
book were you reading mm-hmm and so then
I had to kind of think about what books
was I reading at that time and pick up
pick the funniest one and I picked the
bravest teenage Yanks it was a history
of teenage boys who are in the Union
Army who got the Medal of Honor and
remember I'm fourteen so I'm like look
at the handsome soldiers from the 1860s
I did not date when I was fourteen so I
don't not till like 39 right right
I'm married anyway so yeah yeah okay
that's all she knows yeah she's just
like like do you have a promise would
what's a what's a what's a new premise
that you have well uh the one I've been
bouncing around is like my wife likes to
keep her phone on 1% and I feel like
there's two types of people like people
that are that those adrenaline junkies
and then people that need it charged
like full at all times
is that you that's who I am yeah so I
noticed that and it there's something
there I feel like but I haven't I guess
given it due process right well because
and and what it makes you know there's a
couple of angles of you I could go with
you'd be like well the history of your
own what what's your version of the
adrenaline junkie right it's like what
do you do right or the you are safety
Mouse right and how maybe how is she a
safety Mouse in a different way right
does she have backup toilet paper four
years and then you know it's like
they're just like what's another angle
to your premise so what's another
example of not this trait about me or
her mm-hmm yeah and and and making it
personal it's always nice or you could
try to make it bigger you're just like
well 1% and then you know for no reason
you're like well you know is it because
you've always wanted to be part of the
1% or you know some weird like if you
were one liner kind of college right
something like that yeah yeah I was
thinking there's something with yeah
it's like 1% battery to the
one-percenters I thought there could be
like a Venn diagram to maybe explore
between the similarities and differences
between those right yeah yeah you could
go if you go big then you go global
right then you go like well you know and
then you could be like well what about
the Chinese children who made that and
they go super personal
and just go hey safety Mouse doesn't
think that this is safe or you know or
what your adrenaline what do you do
that's kind of like that you're like
well I'm the kind of guy that likes to
do and this is not that's you know this
is just a it's like I don't do the
dishes at night I leave them I like to
do them in the morning yeah that's
something that she's like yeah what
about the rats
anyway so it's almost like I like that
it's I'm almost like making I'm just as
as we're using the joke machine here
it's almost the example is like she's
this way but I'm no better type deal as
opposed to trying to this this is what's
wrong with her it's like she's that way
but I'm even like worse typed so it's
I'm still like the victim almost we're
able then there's more comedy yeah
making it about your own foibles you
know you're just like I would like to be
the hero of every story but you know and
it's and it's hard kind of it's very
interesting for 30 years I've been doing
jokes but my dad and there's only one
joke that he doesn't like about himself
and in many of the jokes about him he is
a fiery fiery jackass and he doesn't
care about any of those the one joke he
doesn't like it's on the Horcrux album
and it is about an outfit that he met me
at a McDonald's and he was wearing he
was going fishing and I thought it was a
matching denim like shorty shorts and a
sleeveless denim cutoff shirt and he was
like I don't know anything unfinished I
don't that outfit that you're seeing I
was like I don't know dad why would I
make that up he's like I don't know why
but I don't own any cut-offs why would I
own cut-offs I'm like and I was like so
this is the one the one where I call you
I don't know skimming off the top that
doesn't bother you
like you're like questioning your
cowardice your veracity no most fun but
I am dapper so
but but the jokes that I tended I want
it's better if the jokes come from a
place of love even if your earrings
right like even if as mad as you are at
the fact that like I do a joke about the
last time was that my dad is a lot like
I shouldn't we never saw him when we
were children but he affected all of our
lives that is the joke now it is it
comes from a place of you weren't
[ __ ] there where the [ __ ] were you
but if I start doing the choke from that
ankle where the [ __ ] were you that's not
funny
weird radiation analogy that's hilarious
everybody knows exactly what I'm talking
about interesting is that how many ideas
how many have you found you ought to go
through like when you talked about the
book example where Maria was like but
which book will you just list out like
ten books and then just start plugging
them in and whichever one works best
you'll keep kind of it'll be you know
the books that I can remember from when
I read when I was fourteen come to mind
and then and then I just it's not it's
it's not even that deep you know there's
only gonna be four of them and so
whatever seems the silliest you know if
I if I'm the my obsession with the
American Civil War when I was in ninth
grade is hilarious to me and whether or
not because that the the reference to
the book doesn't always work like
audience is just like what what what a
reading a book report and so but I
sometimes say this not just because it's
a tags just for yourself mm-hmm and the
three people that are psyched to get
some weird magic the gathering reference
you know
like hates to come back and hear my Doon
joke is that how you were able because
this is something that every comedian
especially starting out all all
comedians here but I was like finding
your voice finding your voice and I feel
like I mean me personally 10 years in
I'm still exploring it I found ways to
say things that are seemingly starting
to become unique to me but like what was
your process for discovering your voice
and was it material versus how you're
saying it how and how long did it take
you
well it's ongoing right I mean and and
if you're a really good comic your voice
can change and your your you know like
if you look at people's albums like it's
a gift that I know Maria Bamford and I'm
also a giant fan because she will be the
example if you look at her earliest if
you look at each album her voice some
people might think that there's a
through line and there is a through line
in everyone's humanity right I mean
whatever like even if you were to look
at Richard Pryor you know he does family
stuff and he does conflict stuff and he
does stuff about himself and it's all
that's kind of the through like there's
a through there's his life in every is
has been complicated but he has he can
see truth in a lot of things and that's
and the truth is what's funny and it's
what poignant and it's what's
interesting to me anyway mom but you
know 10 years in it's funny when you
start doing stand-up when you're about
two or two-and-a-half years and you're
like oh I get it
and then when you're about seven years
and you're like oh I get it and then ten
years and then at fifteen years and at
thirty years you're just like oh right
there's I swear to god there's no end
I mean do it in my opinion if you're
doing it right you're not you're always
finding another layer and you're finding
another and you have and you have to
sort of mind your life like I don't I
have a
seen Stephen Wright recently he's still
working but um the way he writes as kind
of a would be a fascinating conversation
like this yeah is he so operational
right did you see them oh I have not
just yet full disclosure the new
Seinfeld special I have not yet no okay
yeah and I but I understand it's
Seinfeld is an observational comic and
he he was really really good at it in
the late 80s early 90s and nailed it and
then it got kind of hacked and co-opted
by a lot of new other comics so I guess
the new hour feels a lot like the old
hour but different topics that's what
I've heard yeah yeah I mean I don't know
if you saw Deadpool - but Deadpool - was
exactly like it Deadpool 1 but I loved
Deadpool so I enjoyed Deadpool 2 because
it was just more of that so if you like
you know Seinfeld from 1995 you're gonna
love this because it's just in but
that's you know you can hone things that
are you know somebody asked me probably
10 or 15 years ago they're like you
still talking about your dad
and I became offended and then I was
like oh that's right yeah he's he's
gonna be he's a standard right I mean
he's 84 he said I don't know how long
I'm gonna make it I said I need another
20 minutes from all right fine I'm very
inspired by you saying that it is an
ongoing process though and at every
stage of our career it is like aha oh
now I get it
and then five years later you're like
wait that wasn't no this is it I'm glad
it's just like a never-ending Rubik's
Cube right right and yeah because
there's no done there's no I mean that's
that's if you think you're done I think
that's when that's when the writing can
stagnate and that's when the when the
performance can can solidify you know I
mean I don't I don't know I never saw
Rickles people love rickles right and I
never did see him but I never really got
him either like I did I never thought he
was really for me doesn't mean that he
that he wasn't beloved and then people
were like I'm in it and but I don't know
how much he changed in the 70 years he
did stand-up comedy right yeah yeah so I
think that play the hits there's so many
there yeah and there's so many ways to
do it you know so you don't want like
like that Joan Rivers documentary I
remember watching her set they showed
several sets throughout the documentary
and going oh [ __ ] she's still writing
you know how I guess psyched you know
whatever whenever I meet like a very
bitter you know I'm a road comic right I
mean that's my that's my gig and that is
my bread and butter and whenever I meet
a very particularly bitter Road comic
it's usually someone who stopped writing
you know because I spend a fair amount
of my time or I have and now it's a
point of sort of more muscle memory
where because for the last 20 years you
you said that I that I'm very successful
and I am but I'm not
the successful that you know I
people are like wool weird uh are you on
that flicks and I'm like I've subscribed
I still get the DVDs and but I mean it's
like there's there's things I don't have
right and I may never get an I can't
overthink so I spent a big portion of my
time trying not to plan my attack on the
the industry man
and I can't even get the helium's to
book me so what you know Wow
I mean why would I be like I don't
understand why I don't have an HBO
special you guys I that's that's the
next level for me where I'm just like I
would like to do Philadelphia is there a
way that there's a club and but there's
so so it's interesting the bitterness
that I fight and I think because I was
told early on a couple of things one was
that I was told about Los Angeles that
you have to choose to like it and that's
true of any town that you moved to
because there's there's things to hate
about all of them like if I moved to
Omaha there's probably 200 people in
Omaha that I want to know you know and
it would probably take me three years to
find six of them and because but that's
true of any town right there's probably
200 people in Los Angeles I wanted out
and it's taken me 21 years to find 40 of
them and it's been great you know but
there's 40 people that I love who live
here and so that was one of the best add
pieces of advice I ever got was you
gotta choose to look to like the place
that you're living in it makes sense hmm
and then the other one was you get what
you get and that was Fred Armisen
um Fred Armisen the the year he got
Saturday Night Live we were talking and
he had just found out like a day or so
earlier and we were just hanging out at
a club you just doesn't stand up and he
was like so what are you doing this week
and I said that I was going to Vegas so
do some weird Club and he said oh man I
wish I could do the road and I said what
you just got Saturday night what's
happening and he said I said you could
totally do the road and he goes Jackie
no one's going to tolerate my my costume
changes and
which is what his standard was he would
do these characters which is why it was
kind of perfect and but he would do like
a 7 to 12 minute character and then
which was perfect for Saturday Night
Live and you know we were talking about
the Saturday Night Live versus the road
and he said you know when I what I've
realized is that you get what you get
you know and we both got amazing things
right Saturday Night Live is amazing and
you get to do the road which is really
cool and I'm like yep I mean I genuinely
love the road and I love my life and
it's but you know there's always if I
wanted to be upset and sometimes I do
I could be pissy about what I don't have
and but it is a red flag sort of where
I'm like what is that gonna get you this
if I piss and moan about the thing I
don't have is that gonna get me the
thing I don't have
it is not right yeah and that's that's
what's funny is I'm the grass is always
greener I guess where we were talking
before this if I'm like yeah you're your
fan base you have this engaged loyal fan
base like that's what I'm really trying
to cultivate is like really it doesn't
have to be a Kevin Hart fan base just a
fan base that cares and really wants to
be a part of this community and I was
like knotting my tip of the cap to you
for creating that and it's jut your but
even you are like yeah but this this you
know it could always be better I guess
if I wanted to you know I'm in our heads
yeah yeah yeah margot robbie is probably
sitting in her mansion on scrooge mcduck
pile of money going
why wasn't I offered that gig right I
mean it's always there's always that
level but I will say that about fanbase
in one of one of the greatest inventions
is the is is this sort of technology
which makes it possible for you to for
anyone to do things right
removing the gatekeepers and all this
stuff so I started the dork forest in
2006 and so I just have you know
somewhere between I think it's a
11,000 listeners per week which is not
hundreds of thousands it's not the the
Maron level it's not the Joe Rogan's
level but those even the core sort of
what I think of as the core kind of
three or four thousand of those people
they want on they want I have to hang
out they want to see the thing what what
new thing are you doing and their their
fandom is a enormous ly supportive super
personal and and they all feel like
people that I would hang out with you
know hmm
and yeah I would they're just they're
they're gamers and nerds and they read
too much and they are occasionally
socially awkward and they feel like me
but it's like and we touched on this a
little before we started talking but
there are comics who they end up getting
these fan bases that are I mean the
classic example is of course Dice Clay
right so dice had a character that he
did that was a horrible person and then
some horrible people were like that's my
guy
let's do this well let's Phil Madison
Square Garden with a bunch of [ __ ] bags
and and then you have a hundred thousand
people who love you and you're like well
I should probably take their money
before I leave and just you're trapped
in this weird thing and and then when
you think about louis c.k right where he
was the darling of the alt comedy scene
and his his writing was so heartfelt and
so sort of powerful about the
navel-gazing and the trying to figure
out his own psychological problems that
when one of his real psychological
problems came up and he got called on it
and he admitted to it you know and um
and then he you know he was like yeah
you guys are right that was a shitty
thing to do block door you know have my
dick out its
all hard and you know I've been in
plenty of green rooms with flaccid dicks
because it turns out some dum-dums are
seven year old boys and they're like
trout trout drop but it's really that's
happen to you oh yeah yeah male comic is
just like hello I would say three times
I've had dudes drop their trials because
they think it's funny what these are not
these are not nice men these are not
good right see that look at your face
that's that joke that when I tell a
story like that they're like what did
you tell rate what are you wait you
didn't leak why didn't you just deliver
what why didn't you call the police
whatever and so this is the last gen and
by the way those three guys nice enough
guys you wouldn't want to be alone with
them still around and like they're still
like well-known comics yeah yeah mine
chatroom
yeah we want it oh you don't you can't
actually say it I was just gonna tell
you I wasn't gonna do a podcast with
Laurie kill Martin where we we write
down names of crazy things that have
happened to us oh you could do it in the
chat you were saying yeah it's oh okay
yeah ooh locker room yeah all right you
will be surprised oh no yeah that's
unfortunate nice and if guy right
you just want stand by the door that's
all well you know what's interesting is
like it's I feel like when when I he was
coked up by the way is that well yeah
that adds context but it does seem like
when I'm four people I've interviewed
like when I'm like why aren't they some
were like why aren't they somewhere like
else type dealer why aren't they further
along type deal I've done enough
interviews to where it seems like
there's always a reason yes yeah you can
often tell right you know there's that
that famous seeing
and this isn't it wasn't written
specifically about straight white guys
but it's it's the best example it's the
most purest of hypothesis for the
success rate of straight white guys is
that if you are on time if you are a
genius or if you're easy to work with if
you have all three of them you will go
off the charts
fine if you have two of three you are
employable if you are always late but
you're a genius and you're good to work
with people people will tolerate it if
you're a pain in the ass to work with
but you're a genius and you're always on
time
just don't lose that genius and I love
oh yeah the three trades it's great yeah
it's a it's a it's a weird analogy
nobody fails upward better than Donald
Trump though that guy has failed upward
the whole way okay all right yeah let's
get into some fan questions here as well
sorry to hog the questions here you just
got some momentum I felt very engaged
they're like the more I'm doing these
like over Skype I used to always my rule
was I'll only do them in person so I
would wait for people to come through
Atlanta or when I was out on the road or
something but this is that with dark
forest yeah now we're but at least with
zoom you can we can see each other yeah
I think helps a great deal in Skype Oh
below be finished the whole can I finish
the analogy please cuz we're CK's yeah
cuz Louie CK had this thing where he
admitted that that blocking the door
with his hard dick was a bad thing and
making people watch him finish was gross
and terrible and so he apologized for it
and then he was like I gotta hit a some
time and do some rude numeration and ten
months later he decided that it wasn't
that bad and and so he came back and
he's like it wasn't that bad just yeah
they coulda left it would have been fine
could they have anyway you're you're
really that it's a rationalization
that's nuts but the weird thing is is I
was going to talk about his fanbase
fanbase for so long and I was always I
mean I get it you know I I thought it
was funny
but he was never my I always wanted you
know he had that that policy of doing a
new album every year right and I always
wanted him to give some of those jokes
another 18 months because tighten him up
especially me with I'm super wordy and
it takes three or four years to do a new
album but but his new fans Louis CK's
new fans are a lot of just PLAs you know
deniability kind of weirdos you know and
it's it can't make him happy you know
because they aren't the brightest and
and they're night they're not the
brightest comedy fans what you want is
you want smart fans right you want onyx
you want fans that are gonna get your
jokes and get even your weird references
you don't want people who defend block
it a door with your hard dick that's
what you get when you don't do the work
because there's there's two things about
stand-up comedy one is the stand-up
comedy which is almost as was probably
85% of my life for 17 years and then I
decided that I would like in the rest of
a life a boyfriend
possibly a home maybe a family if I were
to have a baby which I did not and
that's what but um but I decided that I
want and you have to work on that second
part of your life if you are just a
comic for 50 years and you are never the
rest of it like you meet a guy who's a
comic who becomes sort of a better dude
once he starts having kids mmm because
he realizes that there's more to it and
he gets him out of his own head you know
anyway but I was just saying that the
new fan base for Louie CK's of drag
because that guy has and he still has
potential he could still figure out how
to fix his
his the life part of his life which I
think would make his stand-up better
yeah it almost is like going here what
like your audience is almost a mirror of
what you're putting out there right
mm-hmm
and I always bring it back to the stand
I'm like don't you wanna which were
sober up so then you could better stand
up all right cuz you want to stop being
a piece of [ __ ] so that your stand ups
but no I mean and and that is just the
meddler in me I mean it's none of my
business
yeah everybody gets to do whatever they
want to do on stage you know yeah as
long as it's funny like it's like it's
gotta get a lot even if it's if they got
hired you know like I've had any number
of features over the last 35 years where
you're like oh I guess I'll be following
that and you can't there are some
headliners who tell the features what
they can and cannot do and and if you
could afford to you bring your own
feature but um but I've never been a
person to tell people like when I was
coming up there was a there was the club
owner was like the first weekend of
hunting season none of the rest of the
comics of Minnesota could do jokes about
hunting season because he wanted them
all and I was like this is the perfect
storm of a shitty headliner actually
everybody needs to do whatever jokes
they want to do granted if I follow you
and you've done some sort of horrible
racist misogynistic [ __ ] I will
probably mock you openly but that I
won't stop you from doing it and that
actually ties into our first question
perfectly because Justin Williams asked
how do you select your opening comedian
for your tours and have you performed in
Canada yes I've done you know Canada
being Vancouver Winnipeg Montreal
Toronto and Toronto suburbs so that's
what I've done in Canada and then
and I don't always get to pick you know
more and more lately I have been taking
Carmen Morales who did the guest set
today
she's great and she's great she's she's
headlining a lot of clubs already but it
you know how it is on the road it's just
fun to have someone that you want to go
to lunch with and and and she's really
good at joke machine so we we tend to
write together and we she's good people
to hang out with and and I'm like but I
don't make enough money to make it worth
I mean we have to figure out some
routing so that she can like I can bump
her some money for my money and then
she'll make that whatever the shitty
feet your money is and and I can we
could try to find her housing because
features they're not putting features up
anymore but I'm only so many people have
asked me if they could feature for me in
the last 15 years right I've only got to
pick in the last two and there's people
that I've wanted to bring for 15 years
so I'm not really taking new
applications review if you know for
openers you uh you you've opened from
Maria a lot and I'm curious because I
always research my guests and I was
trying to research you in the origin of
that relationship I mean you don't have
to go too far into it but how did y'all
actually meet because it seems like a
magical relationship well 92 at the open
mics in Minneapolis oh okay
yeah should Minneapolis connect I'm a
mini Athas comic oh I moved Aaron 90
she started in 92 and in 2001 I think
the first time we started really going
on the road together where I was opening
for her was in 2001 right after her
burning bridges to her and which is such
a great name because she she ended up
doing a lot of clubs before like she had
you know it's it's like when they sent
it was it was just early she hadn't done
a lot of road road work so she she
thinks
she burned a lot of bridges on that on
that first road run of headlining so she
called her first album the burning
bridges to her and it was right after
that she was like would you be willing
to come with me there's there would be
little or no money because I will have
to pay for your air and then we would
have to share a room we'll get a room
with two beds we don't have to spoon and
then live like a band and and then and
so that was in 2001 was when I first
started going with her and so I would do
her I would do some of her weeks with
her I would do my own weeks and and then
recently I'm doing her weeks that I can
do my own weeks and then I'm also
opening a little bit for problem maybe
twice or three times a year for Brian
Regan very cool and that's super cool
just because you get to watch Brian
Regan three or four times and that's a
delight yeah one of the we've reached
out to his people about being on here
but you know we'll see
yeah I'm just throwing Hail Marys it's
so I'm just like why not uh-huh you
gotta ask you never know you don't ask
you don't get it exactly well that's
good to know what a good agro Wow what I
am what a great ally to have a comic you
started with and you just can continue
to excel together that's great that's a
lot of a lot of the comments I started
with moved out and it found great
success but like my whole mindset
starting comedy was like I'd like to
build it I'd like to build an
independent career with in Atlanta and
show other comics you don't have to move
to create your own success so it's
always been my mindset but to the
hindrance of not being in a New York LA
where you're in the proximity of the
best comics so then that elevates you as
well like there's a there's a pro and
con to each of it of course but right
that's the path I chose yeah and if and
if you have a whole life in Atlanta
mm-hmm and you still get to you win its
yeah yeah thank you thank you all right
so let me uh let's get to the next one
here we have um let me see
Michelle asks if there are any jokes
from the 80s that you still perform
today
no anyway she did follow up yes almost
as like a joke evolution that this may
be able to tie into because also she was
saying as you evolve and grow as a comic
do the standard jokes about your dad or
other topics to those evolved as your
jokes and you evolved I think so
yeah I mean the dad stuff is a good
example like I've been doing jokes about
my dad since the since the beginning I
will occasionally yeah I think like the
oldest joke now those are from the 90s
no but I did write in the eighties in
anyway I there's um there's I think I
did do a joke from it was about and it
was literally I mean in 1984 I think I
wrote a joke about how I took a class in
high school so I was 19 when I started
right and so I was doing jokes about my
high school classes in high school I
took a class called biking and bowling
and I thought that it would be like polo
where we would get on our bikes and bolt
but it was not it was bike to the
bowling alley Bowl bike back home bikes
not included wow I can't believe I
remember this bike this joke
bikes not included my bike was a 1972
lime-green Sears ten-speed a vehicle so
advanced the gears switched by
themselves just this the chain slipped
anyway um but literally that was the
whole joke
there's no laughs in that joke but it's
an interesting image you can see it yeah
right
if I were to do that joke today
I would want some real joke there we
would have to put some cogs and wheels
on that we would have to joke machine
that up just because it's such an
interesting it's an interesting story
image but what would the I don't know
what the bit would be now but it would
have to evolve hmmm nice yeah and
writing is like a muscle that it's like
the more you do it the stronger it gets
so you'll start to like as you are
saying looking at topics from different
angles and I'm sure your point that it's
almost like the matrix or whatever to
where you're just like here's an idea
and then you can just start to kind of
formulate let me think about it from
this angle and maybe I come up from
underneath it or maybe I look at it from
way back here like you just
automatically do it now right there's
there's several there's there are sort
of several filters that I can run it
through immediately to see if there's
something there and then and then
working it out on stage will sometimes
jog other stuff mhm
awesome yeah good question Michelle
chase Bannen he has how important are
transitions to you your albums seem to
flow seamlessly from track to track is
that how you write them or as you
perform does it start making natural
connections what I'm doing right now
with the hours that I'm running on
Thursdays is definitely trying to find
the right order right I mean you were at
the show today mm-hmm the the flirting
bit I was like this doesn't go here
there's no transition there's no segue
there's no nothing but I had to do it so
I just started got into the bit so what
ends up happening is the topics sort of
lead into each other and if they if and
if they don't organically I just move
them into something that has anything to
do with it if there's if I've mentioned
my dad and then there's a tiny story
that about my husband and then all of a
sudden hey it's the married chunk and
then I've talked about my husband and
then at the end of that there's some
weird social justice thing that I'm like
oh we could talk about
the nature of good dudes versus dirtbag
dudes and whatever because I mean it's
weird the topics that everybody's doing
right now is there's so much parallel
thought because you would think there
would be more just because we all have
all this information but it's
interesting it's like oh all right I
guess we're all doing something about
gender we're all doing something weirdly
enough a lot of people doing stuff about
Schrodinger's cat doing that joke about
six months ago since then four different
comics talking about Schrodinger's cat
mm-hmm
I have a different analogy and a
different angle on it but you know as
far as I'm concerned it'll help people
remember who Schroedinger is easier for
a bit what is your opinion on parallel
thought but we do it we do a daily
writing Club in this group it's where we
meet up and we get a random word and
then we write for 10 minutes and just as
an exercise and that's that's come up a
few times it was like parallel thought
and if you do have a parallel thought do
you kill it or do you if it's a
different angle like you said you keep
it like what's your opinion on parallel
thought I think that it's if you have a
different angle it's it's certainly not
a problem right if it's exactly the same
joke and that person did it on an album
or on television that's you know there's
very levels to it right
I had an album out I think it was the
bread album that I did the LA Pet joke
and it was about it was a long bit about
the pet owners in Los Angeles there's an
animated copy of it it's a very
beautiful animated you dumb hair love
the oscar-winning short animated short
this year the guy who that guy steam
animated my la pet joke very exciting
thanks oh and he's [ __ ] genius that
joke that la pet joke is a great joke he
puts so many awesome images behind it
that made it I would say twice as funny
if not three times as funny he was
amazing anyway but the LA pet joke in
one of the jokes cuz all my bits
start out six minutes they end up three
minutes there's five or six punchlines
and one of the punchlines was about how
it was $3,000 for diabetic cat medicine
that's 3,000 new cats because cats are
free that's the joke and I did it it
would have been 10 years ago so about
four years ago I was still doing that
bit I think maybe five maybe six years
ago five years ago and I'm still doing
that bit and I did it one night at The
Improv it was just a showcase line up a
bunch of to 10-minute sets right and
three or four comics after me Tom Papa
went up and Tom Papa hilarious beautiful
writer beautiful comic went up destroyed
for his ten to fifteen or whatever he
did but he had the exact same joke three
thousand dollars for diabetic cat
medicine three thousand ducats cats are
free verbatim so he destroyed for his
entire chunk except that joke which they
had just heard me do dead silence he
comes off stage and I said well hey uh I
just did that job and he was like what I
just bought diabetic camp medicine for
my cat like three weeks ago three weeks
ago and I was like yeah I did it six
years ago and I don't think he knew that
was on my album because he put it on his
special whoa yeah but it was literally
parallel fun right yeah and I have never
gotten any guff from anyone going hey
you stole it from Tom papa
and I would hope that he wouldn't get
any guff day you stole it from Jackie
Kashian
seems something but the but yeah
parallel thought is it's real and it and
it also if you think about it even if it
isn't parallel thought like when my
stuff is almost impossible to steal but
the premises aren't but but I think the
bits are kind of hard to steal I had a
friend of mine in the 90s who had he
insisted his married Barbie joke stolen
that Barbie got divorced
and so if you buy the divorce Barbie it
comes with all of Ken's [ __ ] that was
the joke I the hilarity anyway but it's
a very 1997-98 joke and he was talking
to me and Matt Weinhold comic from San
Francisco really funny guy he's got it
he's got one album of these mostly a
writer now but he had been called
funhouse I think that Matt why not but
he we were trying to explain to Dave
that you just write another joke man
just write another joke if someone
steals your joke and puts it on
television you're screwed there's
nothing there you have no recourse and
here's the good news you're probably a
better writer mmm then that person and
you will continue to write jokes I love
it
oh and this can fall into our final
question here from Danny hugs who
actually asked speaking of writing how
do you break writer's block
ah I have a thing that I pulled actually
I think I pulled it out of the the
artists way you know that book yes and
it was but it's one of my favorite was
one of my favorite tools that she put in
one of the back of the chapters it was
to break your life into five-year chunks
hmm like if I if you know how like when
you write you write and then we dry up
and there's a plateau and if you're
lucky you got enough premises to work on
until the next burst of premises show up
but pardon me
the it's not the wrong though every
every time someone coughs right wait was
that it was up there oh no but so but if
you break your life into five-year
chunks 0 to 5 and the interesting happen
to you or a loved one when you were a
zero or five years old anything
interesting happens 6 to 10 anything
interesting happen 11 to 15 16 to 20 21
and as I get older
holy smokes just breaks it up you can
look into your life in five-year chunks
you can look into your siblings parents
extended fan
life then you branch up what was
happening in your town in those five
years and then you can happen what was
happening in your race what was
happening in your gender what was
happening in your sexuality what was
happening in world politics what was
happening in specific in the middle of
Ghana what was happening in Ghana in
1998 whatever you know and you can you
can just widen the circle and if you
keep widening it you will find a promise
and and then you'll write a joke and it
won't be very good and then you'll keep
writing so don't worry about it because
eventually you'll write like a signature
bit if you keep doing stand-up comedy
and you're any good at it or have a kind
of an aptitude because I don't know I
don't know if it's a learned the we're
one of the weirdest things I learned
early on not even early on middle on is
that I used to think that if you were
smart enough you could and and funny and
understood it you could anyone could do
stand-up if you were smart and funny and
then I met a woman who was incredibly
smart very dark very funny
horrible cop holy [ __ ]
she was terrible she the audience hated
her from the moment she opened her pile
hmm and I was like what is she doing and
she had it was not it wasn't even it was
it was stage presence which everyone is
born with now right all the new baby
comics that are coming up they all have
good dental and and they all are better
looking like when I started doing
stand-up it was usually just crazy
people and the unattractive who did
stand-up and and then if you're Paul
Provenza you get put through a rock
tumbler and you end up being handsome so
it's all nice but the but yeah
all in all the new comics and it's so
interesting to see really good looking
young comics and I'm like why are you
funny and then you remember that they
were all raised on like adderall and and
then and they were all on like
antipsychotics growing up because their
parents couldn't handle it and then they
turned 18 and started smoking pot and
drinking booze and now it's a cocktail
and they make themselves crazy but
they're still good-looking and then
they're funny I don't know it's just
it's a theory
speculation amazing we went from
writer's block to now the young
attractive generation but how some some
people wait urine you use that lady as
an example of she was very smart very
funny but would walk an audience but I'm
sure you've been to a comedy long enough
to where it seems like some people it
takes them 15 years if they just stick
with it they eventually maybe have a
breakthrough like if you just keep
banging your head against the wall
eventually it'll crack right right and
it doesn't and if you're banging your
head against the right well I always say
this if you're banging your head against
the right wall it doesn't mean it
doesn't hurt your head but you were at
least found the correct wall here's a
good story that maybe it may end on but
so there was a guy doing a one-nighter
it was oh it's a weekend room that isn't
there anymore outside of Minneapolis and
and there was a guy who'd been doing
stand-up for easily 15 years and he came
and he the club was like no we got him
doing a Chris is gonna do a guest set
and my buddy came literally he was like
the guy did the guest set he came
offstage and dave said that he went up
to him and he said you have to stop
doing stand-up comedy I've been watching
you for 15 years you've never had a good
set you've never said anything funny and
I was like what the [ __ ] did you do he's
terrible and I said yeah it has nothing
to do with you he was like it was on my
show and I said well you can tell him
that he can't do guess that's on your
show but you can't tell me
stand-up comedy and he goes he has to
stop and he said well Jackie here's the
thing I went to him and I totally sucked
and he never said anything funny and it
been 15 years and he had to stop you
know what happened the next day was a
Friday Saturday he showed up on Saturday
for a guest set and I was like that's
cuz he wins he wins Dave you don't win
that guy as bad as he is he said he used
to open up with this terrible Cabbage
Patch Kid joke
he was never funny I'm like if a Cabbage
Patch Kid and another thing turned into
a poof you know it's me oh my gosh Oh 15
years in still doing I look like X Y Z
oh boy gotcha oh well thank you
yeah yeah I guess that's good yeah I
trust your opinion on that on terms of
but you can't tell him you can't do
stand-up comedy
you can't stand up comedy is like is
like telling somebody if they say what
they're doing is a stand-up comedy it's
stand-up comedy if you're Gallagher and
you're breaking crap
it's stand-up comedy if you have a
rubber chicken and you're waving it at
the world it is stand-up County if you
are the driest [ __ ] in the world
that's standup county and if it's
storytelling if it's one-liners that's
the you can't tell somebody that they're
not doing stand-up comedy you can see
you could say for me and I say that so
as we closing advice here you know
you've been doing comedy over 30 years
so what what advice are core
listenership are comedy nerds and more
specifically like comedians that are
just out there on the grind it's like
what kind of advice could you bestow
upon us moving forward in our comedy
careers well what I would say is that if
you want the full version of this in
1985 I think I met my first comic I was
given this advice and I framed it and I
put it on the wall
in my bathroom hmm and I don't know why
it's in the bathroom but there it is Oh
what does that mean that didn't take but
it was its advice that that this woman
wrote and she still does stand up she
stopped doing it for about ten years
and ended up she ended up doing it again
after like a ten-year gap where she was
teaching yoga to the Dixie Chicks I
think and so she was very much a groover
right and but her advice is the same
advice I would give anyone you just um
just the best advice was probably be
patient and have fun those were the two
my two favorites
I just tried it's on my way it's on the
front page my website it's the advice I
got when I first started doing comedy
it's a link on the front page where I
left the link looks broken gonna have to
talk to my web guy anyway
but the advice is essentially be patient
with your creativity and be patient with
your career because there will be
plateaus and there will be leaps and
there will be valleys and and have fun
makes works with that because if you are
having fun every show and you can't by
the way you can't have fun on every show
sometimes you're in your head too much
but if you remind yourself to have fun
you will have more fun than if you do
not remind yourself to have fun I
remember I got off stage at Last Comic
Standing the semifinals and billed Dwyer
was right in front of me he had just
done his five-minute set he got off
stage he grabbed me by the shoulders and
he goes guess what once you get out
there it's just stand-up Cody you're
gonna be great and then he kept moving
which was the greatest pep talk in the
world right yeah so yeah so be patient
with your career with your creativity
and with some and remember to have fun
all right well this was so much fun
Jackie please let let the hot breath
verse no like where they can follow you
support you join your your whole world
you have well I'm going to fix that link
and then you can look at it
the advice if you go to Jackie Kashian
comm and Jackie Kashian comm is easy
enough because it's also family pet
ancestry.com dating back to that old le
pet jet which I bought and they pet I
bought La Paz I bought family pet
ancestry.com because it made me laugh
but now they are actually doing DNA
tests of people's pets and it's
completely bananas so if you go to add
alt it's just at Jackie Kashian
twitter facebook Instagram all snapchat
all the things and I have two podcasts
the dark forest
where I interview people about what they
love and a lot of it if you have a
favorite comic or a favorite dork 'dom
if you type in the words the dork Forest
and the name of your favorite comic
they've probably done an episode mmm
it's like Kathleen Madigan talking about
the Kennedys is particularly one so guy
brand I'm talking about the Mitford
sisters also a delight all the things
Marin talking about blue jeans weird
anyway so Jimmy Pardo talking about the
band Chicago anyway so but you can you
can do whatever you want and and then I
have another podcast entirely about
stand-up comedy where Lori Kilmartin and
I celebrate and [ __ ] about it for one
hour each week the Jackie Laurie show
and you should have Kilmartin on she
writes for Conan true bro comic for sure
and yeah yeah
and is it delight yeah yeah we'd love to
have Lori on yeah that'd be great
awesome well that is the it hot breath
averse go forth support Jackie and all
she's doing we will link all of that in
the description if you are watching this
later or listening to this later go into
the description click join this Facebook
group you're missing out if you're not
in here so we're getting comics like
Jackie on here this nowhere else is
doing this I mean come on so go forth
follow this advice Thank You Jackie for
your time and valuable wisdom
[Music]